Narrator:
Tonight on "Shark Tank"...
‐Oh.
‐Wow.
‐Whoa!
Okay, that's cool.
Our customers call our product
a life‐saver.
[ Laughing ] It's cold!
Did I hear
you're a royalty business?
Very similar
to a royalty business.
Yippee‐i‐o‐ki‐yay.
[ Laughter ]
You are drowning
in opportunity.
What have you sold?
$56.
Our biggest obstacle
is capital.
Ooh, that's a bad idea.
That sucks.
I don't trust you
with my money.
I'll give you $400,000.
Mark,
are you in or out?
$75 million.
Whoa!
It's the American dream.
♪♪
Narrator:
First in the Tank
is a product to help kids
sleep more soundly.
♪♪
Hi!
Hi.
Hi, Sharks. I'm Katy,
and this is my mom, Lou.
We're from
Atlanta, Georgia,
and we're here seeking
$400,000
in exchange for 20%
of our company, SlumberPod.
♪♪
Traveling with your kiddos
can be crazy stressful.
Whether you're in a hotel room
or crashing at Grandma's,
it can be a nightmare to share
a room with a little one.
Many babies need total darkness
to sleep well.
Parents often resort
to crazy stuff,
like building dangerous,
homemade forts.
Herjavec: What is
that mother doing? What?!
Are those jumper cables?
[ Chuckles ]
Or, if things really start
to get crazy,
taping aluminum foil
to the windows.
Lou: Parents don't deserve
to be sleep‐deprived
and miserable on trips.
[ Laughter ]
So, we decided to kick
those sleepless nights
to the curb
and create our own
easy solution.
Both: SlumberPod!
Yay!
It's a portable
privacy pod
that gives your baby its own
dark and private place to sleep.
It's a tent.
Once your SlumberPod
is assembled,
simply slide it over
your travel crib.
And just like that...
[ Laughter ]
...sleep is moments away.
Greiner:
Poor little baby!
[ Laughter ]
Designed with your baby's
safety in mind...
...it's made
of breathable fabric...
Oh, no.
[ Child crying ]
[ Laughter ]
Cuban:
That kid is not having it.
Aww!
Lou: SlumberPod is made
of breathable fabric,
it weighs less
than 6 pounds,
and best of all,
it fits in carry‐on luggage.
Our customers call our product
a life‐saver,
a game‐changer,
and a marriage‐saver.
I don't know!
[ Laughter, crying continues ]
Sharks, don't sleep
on this amazing opportunity.
Ohh.
So, who's ready
to join us
in creating
more nighty‐nights?
Next time,
use a fake baby.
Herjavec:
Let the child out!
[ Crying continues ]
‐Aww!
‐Alright, Oscar.
It's okay.
Oh, my gosh, great job!
Good night, Oscar.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
Those are real tears, damn it!
Real tears!
Believe it or not,
Oscar actually sleeps in this
every night at home.
He's just having
a little stage anxiety.
Lou: Thank you.
‐Bye.
‐Bye, Oscar.
The slumber prison
costs how much, and what
do you sell it for?
[ Laughs ]
"Slumber prison."
We sell for $149.99,
and the landed cost is $56.
Lou, how did you come up with
the idea of a tent for children?
So, when I was home
for the Christmas holidays
when my oldest daughter
was a year and a half,
we had to stay
in the same room with her.
That room didn't have
great window treatments,
so some light
was coming through...
Mm.
...and she kept waking up
in the night,
seeing us
across the room,
and not understanding that
she needed to stay in the bed
and that it wasn't time
to wake up.
I think we got two or three
hours of sleep a night
two nights in a row,
to the point where
we went home a day early.
Like, sleep deprivation
is a military torture tactic
because it makes you
miserable and crazy, right?
So are twins.
Yeah.
That's a good point also.
[ Laughter ]
How long will it take you
to put it back in a box?
Breaking it down probably takes
two minutes or less,
and then putting in the bag,
another 30 seconds.
Must you have
the Pack 'n Play?
Otherwise, the child
crawls out from under it.
That's a great question,
Barbara.
So, it also fits
a toddler cot inside,
or you could make a pallet
on the floor out of blankets.
And it's not designed
to confine a child.
It's designed to create
a dark and private
sleep environment.
It looks
really complicated.
There are instructions
sewn right into the bag.
It's simple as setting up
a camping tent.
And, you know, it may look
a little bit...
cumbersome...
Scary.
...but what you make up for that
is in how small it gets.
That's what allows it
to fit in carry‐on luggage.
Have you started
selling them?
Yes.
How much are your sales?
We launched in August,
and then this year,
we've done $556,000.
‐Wow.
‐That's really good.
‐Man!
‐What a surprise.
How? Why, Lou?
How and why did it take off?
Because moms
are obsessed.
They love to talk
about things that work,
and they love to put it
on Instagram.
No advertising?
We've done
very limited advertising.
So, you guys have got to be
just so profitable
and just generating cash,
printing money.
We became profitable
in February.
We have no debt.
What is your background?
Tell us about you.
I actually went back
to college
as a single mom
at 39 years old...
Good for you.
‐Good for you.
‐Wow.
...and got
my master's degree at 50,
and I've worked for Fortune 500
and small software companies.
Cuban: Good for you.
Um, so that's
my background.
How about you, Katy?
She's also a mom
to six kids,
and I'm the oldest
of those kids.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm in the automotive space
currently,
and I'm a mom to three.
I have
3‐year‐old twins.
So, I think about sometimes,
if I had given away
a percentage of my business,
would it have been
right for me?
Or was it better that I had
to figure out everything
and do it myself,
which made me stronger,
smarter, better,
and not a one‐person company
anymore?
I don't say this often,
but I think you should
continue to do
what you're doing.
Because I truly
believe that,
I'm going to go out.
Thank you.
Obviously, we have
mixed feelings
about that response,
but thank you.
[ Laughs ]
I want to add
to Lori's story, if I may,
because something
happened to me
that was a real lesson
in my career.
I was in a terrible
real‐estate recession,
I owed the whole world
so much money,
and, as luck
would have it,
Merrill Lynch came
and offered to buy my business.
They offered me $250,000.
But here's what happened ‐‐
they changed their mind,
and I thought the sky
had fallen.
And do you know,
it was only five years later
I sold my business
for $66 million?
To Lori's valid point,
be careful
when you sell your stock.
But that being said, I want
to take advantage of you.
♪♪
Narrator: One Shark is out,
but Barbara may be interested
in Lou and Katy's
child sleeping tent, SlumberPod.
Be careful
when you sell your stock.
But that being said, I want
to take advantage of you.
[ Laughter ]
That's the truth.
She's nothing
if not honest, right?
So, I'm gonna offer you
$400,000 for 25%,
but I have
one contingency.
I don't want to wait forever
to be paid back.
Every time you sell something ‐‐
you name the number ‐‐
I just want some
kind of a payment
so that I know
I'm getting paid back first,
get that money out.
But I'll be
a terrific partner.
And I need you to answer ‐‐
O'Leary: Katy and Lou,
I'm gonna put some pressure
on Barbara.
Wait.
And I need you
to answer me now.
25%, that's a savage offer
and greedy,
and I don't like that.
That's not greedy at all.
I do not appreciate
that kind of greed.
I'm gonna loan you $400,000
at 9% for three years.
That'll cover
all your inventory costs.
And I'm going to take
7% equity for that loan.
You're getting
a bidding war going here.
Oh, there's just greed
and reasonableness.
Come on, Robert.
[ Clicks tongue ]
Barbara made you
a really fair offer.
I would've made
a more aggressive offer.
I'm out.
Thank you.
O'Leary: Mark, are you in?
Guys, I'm gonna share a story
similar to Barbara's.
When we had started
broadcast.com as AudioNet
and we were the first streaming
company in the country
and Microsoft got
into that business
and Microsoft
invited us up
and we started talking
about an offer ‐‐
And to Barbara's point,
we thought we were right there
for an offer that was gonna be
for $75 million.
Gosh,
better than my story.
Didn't get that offer.
But, two years later,
we sold for $5.7 billion
because we didn't take
that offer.
I'm out.
This is more than money.
We're looking for someone
to help us scale.
Exactly.
We're looking
for those relationships.
You just don't have to give
all that up.
They want to help you.
Of course they want
you to be successful.
Yeah.
♪♪
Barbara, would you do
our original deal?
Yeah, I would.
Let's do it.
We'll do it.
[ Cheers ]
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Congratulations.
‐Whoo!
‐Congratulations!
‐Come give me a hug!
‐I'm coming, baby.
[ Laughter ]
I really wanted to squeeze you
on the money,
but you're too nice.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
What a nice job
you did with her.
‐Congratulations.
‐Congrats, ladies.
Congratulations, ladies.
Biggest sale ever done
in pajamas.
[ Laughs ]
We did it!
Both: We made a deal
with Barbara!
Yes!
I mean, making a deal
with Barbara,
it's a dream come true.
She is a female Shark,
which is
what we were hoping for,
and she just seems like
she'll be an incredible partner.
And to be able to grow
our business together
with my daughter
is a dream come true.
♪♪
O'Leary:
I've invited my companies
to the Delano South Beach
for my annual
Mr. Wonderful summit.
My team is here,
18 of my companies are here,
and the key to this event
is learning.
Welcome to the second annual
Mr. Wonderful summit.
Now, let's get to work.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We've got workshops,
we've got guest speakers,
Instagram and Facebook and more.
They're gonna be sharing
the latest trends
in social media
and technology.
We're gonna go through this
just like school.
I really want to dive
into how, specifically,
you can use Instagram Stories
to get people excited about
what your business has to offer.
You have three seconds
in a sub‐1‐minute video
to grab their attention.
To reach customers that
you're already interacting with,
you can use custom audiences.
LovePop is inherently
about connections
between people,
so we do a lot
on social media,
and these workshops
are invaluable.
Do you ever wake up
and you have, like,
a voice in your head?
O'Leary: It's not easy
to be an entrepreneur.
I've asked Sara from Honeyfund
to talk to the group
about the more personal side
of running a business.
[ Voice breaking ]
I can admit my failures
and learn from them.
That's one thing
that I actually consider
to be one of my superpowers.
When we come together
in these summits,
there's this magic moment
where we just start to really
open up to each other as humans,
and that's where
we really grow together.
Both my mother and father
had Alzheimer's disease.
If it weren't for family
and coworkers,
it could've been
a total disaster.
There were mistakes made
and failures,
and it was hard to get back up.
As a new person here, there's
almost a sense of family.
So, if you do have problems,
reach out to somebody.
We've got a special group.
O'Leary: All of my entrepreneurs
are going home
with a brand‐new set of weapons
to build their business with,
but now it's time
for a big family dinner.
Remember, entrepreneurship
is not a destination.
This is a journey.
Enjoy this evening,
and let's have a great toast
to success.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm so proud of the companies
here tonight.
Collectively,
their sales are $178 million
since they came on "Shark Tank."
These companies
are my Wonderful legacy.
I'm giving back. I'm investing
in these young entrepreneurs.
The results
are absolutely spectacular.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is apparel
for the most extreme climates.
♪♪
It's a yeti.
[ Chuckles ]
Hi, Sharks. I'm Dale Lewis,
founder of Fortress Clothing.
I'm seeking $600,000
for 15% equity in my company.
The problem
with cold‐weather clothing is,
once you're cold, you get sweaty
and cold and wet.
And once you're wet,
your day is over.
Fortress has solved
that problem.
So, I can lose the parka...
I can lose the hoodie...
I don't need a windbreaker...
and this long‐sleeved tee
goes away.
You just lost
a lot of weight.
Corcoran:
Wow, you look better.
‐Thank you.
‐[ Laughs ]
Lewis: Fortress delivers
on three promises,
due to our patented, innovative
disruptive technology.
Number one ‐‐
you'll be warm even if wet.
And number two ‐‐ you'll be warm
with fewer additional layers.
And three ‐‐
an amazing comfort spectrum.
Skyler, how cold is it
over there in the tank?
‐112 Fahrenheit.
And it's gonna prove
how amazing his product is.
And, Robert, since you had
the opportunity
of being in a cryotank
several years ago,
we brought special samples
for you
to experience the technology.
‐Oh, I want to try it.
‐Oh, yeah. Put him in the tank!
Lewis:
You got to get in there.
Let me take you back
to our samples.
♪♪
Crank it up, buddy.
250 below.
Alright.
You guys got it.
[ Air hisses ]
Greiner: [ Chuckles ]
Lewis: So, Lori.
Yes.
This is special‐made for you.
It's our prototype.
[ Gasps ] I love it.
Together with our
winter gloves,
the warmest gloves
you'll ever own.
Thank you.
Being a Canadian, I know
you'll absolutely appreciate
a nice vest
with our all‐purpose gloves.
Cool.
Barbara,
this is our hoodie.
We did this
on a Kickstarter.
Ooh, I love hoodies.
And, Mark.
Pleasure to meet you.
This is our parka
together with our ski
or snowmobile gloves.
Cuban: Cool.
What are you wearing?
So, I'm wearing
our base layer.
I think it looks cool,
but if you say
it's as warm as it is,
look how sleek it is.
Yeah, this is comfortable
from 70 down to ‐10 degrees.
That's amazing.
And we also manufacture gear.
O'Leary: Robert,
I'm ready for you.
Is that what Robert has on,
Dale? The base layer?
So, yeah, typically,
you wear this next to skin.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Go like this, Robert.
‐So, come on in.
‐Put him in.
Throw him in.
Are you ready?
I'm ready.
Okay.
Corcoran: [ Laughs ]
Lock him up.
Oh, my God.
Okay, hit him.
Let's go to 300 below.
Lewis: So, the longer the door
is shut, the colder it gets.
‐I'm worried.
‐Hit him again!
Skyler:
Are you guys worried?
O'Leary: I'm not worried.
I'm not worried.
Greiner: Robert,
are you breathing?
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughing ] It's cold!
‐How are your hands?
‐It's cold!
[ Laughter ]
Are you okay?
Oh, that's good.
Oh, God.
So, Dale,
who is my market?
Am I trying to sell
to the people
that are working
in extreme temperatures?
I mean, there's not
too many places on Earth
that are 200 below zero.
Right.
Okay.
How did it feel?
It ‐‐ It's freezing.
Like, my toes are ‐‐
Really?
They feel like they're gonna
fall off, seriously.
Really?
But really incredible ‐‐
the top, nothing.
The top was good.
Wow.
So, we have a proprietary
disruptive insulation technology
that is amazing.
In all of these products?
All of these products
contain our insulation.
Well, let's define
our market.
‐Yes.
‐Who are we going after?
Okay, so, why am I here?
Because I need
an influencer with power,
and I need
your distribution channels.
So, what have you sold?
So, we have historically sold
$3.5 million
company to‐date since 2012.
Wow.
Seven years?
You've been doing this
since ‐‐
So, what did you do
the last 12 months?
Uh, well, 2018,
we did $407,000.
The issue is, we had
all this great growth,
built a reputation,
and oil, if you'll remember,
went from $80 to $100
to $140 and then, boom, bust,
down to $30‐something
a barrel.
That was
your primary market?
You're trying to sell
to the industrial client?
Yes. See, the problem is,
we have so much opportunity.
We could be everywhere.
So, we were trying
to be focused on oil.
Well, what that did is, it made
it so we couldn't stay alive.
But you want to go
into full retail now?
What do you want to do?
Greiner: Well,
but wait a minute.
How are you different
from your competitors?
So, the value proposition
is that we do
the three things we claim ‐‐
one, you can be
soaking wet and warm.
But does it breathe?
Does it let in ‐‐
So, let's say
you fall into...
Why is it solved for wet?
You're ice fishing,
and you fall in.
Like, it's
freezing‐cold water.
Yes.
What happens?
So, I have a video
to demonstrate that.
Oh.
This is me.
I'm wearing
our Fortress layer
and then just
some basic underwear.
‐Oh, my gosh!
‐You're not gonna do that.
‐Don't do it!
‐This is 3 1/2 feet of ice,
and it really sucks.
‐No!
‐Ohh!
‐Oh, my gosh!
Lewis: This is so horrible.
You'll see by my face it is...
Ohh!
Ohh.
‐It's so dangerous.
‐Ugh!
You cannot breathe.
But that's in the water.
Once you get
out of the water,
within 45 seconds,
you are absolutely warm.
I am curious about you,
though.
Are you a scientist?
What's your background?
No, no, no.
So, you'll love this.
I'm a serial entrepreneur,
had three colossal failures,
seven years of famine.
[ Voice breaking ]
You, uh...
Excuse me.
Where you're so poor,
it affects your self‐esteem.
Like, I'm serious.
We have eight children,
and, um, I was trying to hook up
this new business,
and each time ‐‐
My kids bet me how long
it would be before I cried.
Aww.
O'Leary:
The bad times are gone.
[ Laughs ]
You have eight kids,
Dale?
Yeah.
That would make me cry, too.
[ Chuckles ]
Anyway. [ Clears throat ]
Excuse me.
The fourth one
was this awesome success.
Excuse me. [ Sighs ]
Okay, and...
So, you blow up three times,
and the fourth is magic.
Blow up three times,
the fourth one was magic.
So, now the fun part.
I built
a telecommunications company
from zero to $33 million
over nine years.
I'm assuming
you sold this.
And then I had a liquidity event
and retired when I was 40.
And ‐‐ Thank you.
It's the American dream.
It really is.
Yes, it is.
O'Leary: What's missing
in this deal is,
it's undefined
where I go next.
I don't know
where to go with this thing.
I give you my $600,000,
and I don't know
how I get it back,
'cause I'm only getting
15% of the company,
and you haven't really decided
what you're gonna do.
‐No, no, no.
If you're going
after the fashion space,
then you're competing
with all these mega marketers.
Right.
‐Yep.
‐That's very hard.
But you haven't done
any of that stuff.
You're selling direct
to guys in the oil field.
So, that's where I think
I'm coming to you
and saying I'm looking
for the low‐hanging fruit.
You are influencers, and
you have distribution channels.
You don't have
a market to find.
No, right now,
we're gonna continue
to do the industrial workwear
together with the outdoorsmen.
Corcoran: Dale, if you had
patented technology,
did you not think
about selling the technology
to people
who manufacture clothing,
versus do it yourself?
We did, and we were told no,
because it was
an unproven technology.
They wanted market validation,
and that is why
we created Fortress ‐‐
to go get market validation.
I see.
O'Leary: Here's a question.
I like the style
of that...Catwoman thing.
The base layer.
That looks interesting.
Greiner: Me too.
Now,
I ski in St. Moritz.
It's the coldest mountain
in Switzerland.
It's about 28 below
on the top.
Awesome.
And I want to look great
when I get down to the cabine.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐Alright?
If I just wore that,
I'd look great on the mountain,
which I care about.
No. No, no, no.
Then you'd wear
your outer shell of choice.
Why can't I just wear this,
what you're wearing,
to go skiing?
Greiner: With nothing, yeah.
Oh, 'cause it doesn't have
a wind‐stop.
It doesn't have
the wind stopper?
So, think of this
as insulated thermal underwear.
Okay.
Normally, you'd just throw
some sort of shell over it.
Greiner: Here's what's
confusing for me.
I think the look is good,
the technology sounds good,
but I'm still not getting
how this is gonna beat
what else is out
on the market.
And the thought
of a shell on top, for me,
disconnects to how cool
I think the look is,
'cause it takes away from that.
I don't think
I'm the right partner.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
Okay. I think maybe
after a little while,
you might come back in.
So...
[ Laughter ]
Corcoran: Let me say
a couple of things.
Please.
I think
your best positioning
is that you are
Fortress underwear company.
Yeah.
You drop on a parka,
you go skiing.
you go ice fishing.
You drop on a parka,
it's just a thin layer.
It's a good idea.
And I think also having
all these garments
is confusing
for a consumer.
I think it should be one thing
that applies to many industries.
What's wrong with positioning
as an underwear company?
That caught my attention.
And we're open to that.
Well, I'm not open to it.
Oh, okay.
Because
it came too late.
That's a good idea, Barb.
But I...
Yeah, but it would be
a whole new business
you'd have to build.
You know, Fortress
long underwear, right?
So, I wish I had the energy
for that and enthusiasm for it.
But sadly, I am out.
You know, Dale,
it's missing focus on marketing,
and I have a very hard time
parting with $600,000
to test different ideas.
I can't go there with you.
I don't see a strategy.
I'm out.
Herjavec: Dale, I have to
tell you, I love this,
but the message,
it's so confusing!
You're selling
to oil workers.
Then you're jumping into water
in the Arctic somewhere.
But he needs direction.
And let me clarify.
Dale, I can't do it.
I can't do it.
No, I know.
I really wanted you
to get me excited.
[ Sighs ]
But I got to
tell you, man,
you are drowning
in opportunity.
I know.
I just want to be successful
in one category. That's it.
I would've been happy
to go along for that niche.
But, my friend...
But that's what I'm saying ‐‐
I'm sorry.
Too much opportunity
for me.
I'm out.
Dale, you've sold
technology before.
Congrats on your successes.
When you're trying
to sell technology,
it has to be clean
and simple
how you're differentiated
and why you're better.
If the bodysuit,
if you told me I could
just go skiing,
I could go running,
and as long
as it's not windy,
you're gonna be
completely warm
and you're gonna be
comfortable, great.
Mm.
Right?
That's something
to look at.
But that's not
what you conveyed to me,
and to their point, you're
bouncing around a little bit
because you're trying to say
you want to do too much.
I think you'll figure it out,
but for those reasons,
I'm out.
Alright.
Good luck, Dale.
Thanks.
Appreciate your time.
‐Do the long underwear.
‐Okay.
Lewis: I am absolutely shocked
because I expected
two or three Sharks
to get in on this deal.
I think I confused them,
and my bad ‐‐
I should've done
a better job communicating.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a business
capitalizing on the personal
electric vehicle trend.
♪♪
‐Oh.
‐There you go.
‐Hey!
Okay, that's cool.
Both: Hey, Sharks!
My name is Chico.
And my name's Mason.
We're both
from Portland, Oregon,
and our company
is Zuum Technologies.
We're here seeking
a $125,000 investment
in exchange
for 20% of our company.
The trend
towards electric rideables
has been taking the U. S.
by storm!
From electric scooters
popping up
all over cities overnight
to everyone and their mother
wanting a hoverboard,
consumers are fascinated with
the idea of electric rideables,
and they're eager
to hop onto the trend.
That's where we got the idea
to start our company
and introduce Zuum shoes
to the market.
Zuum shoes
are individual self‐balancing
platforms for your feet
that go up to a top speed
of 8 miles per hour,
with an average ride time
of 1 hour.
Mason, why don't we show
the Sharks how they work.
Let's do it.
With Zuum shoes,
there are a ton of different
ways you can ride them.
You can easily
maneuver through,
as well as over,
different objects.
But the best part
about Zuum shoes is,
you can practice
your sick dance moves.
Hit it, Chics!
[ Beatboxing ]
[ Laughter ]
Wow, just like Kevin.
We're two young
entrepreneurs
that are dedicated
to making electric rideables
accessible to the masses.
Both: So, Sharks,
who wants to hop on early
and Zuum with us
towards the future?
I want to try it.
Remember your children.
Mark, you want to try?
No.
Alright,
make sure you get on.
And, yeah, you basically
just lean forward to go forward.
‐Oh, my God.
‐Oh, my God, they're so cool.
Backwards
to go backwards.
Greiner: Do you feel like
you're gonna fall off?
Ah, come on, Lori,
it's me.
[ Laughs ]
Whoo!
Come on, baby!
Aah!
Bye, Robert!
[ Laughs ] Lock the doors!
Bye!
‐Whoo!
‐Oh, he's got it down.
‐Oh!
Cuban: Yeah,
that whole stop thing.
Greiner: Wait, wait, wait.
Could he stop himself or not?
It's like a hoverboard.
Getting on is not hard.
It's getting off
that's hard.
Exactly.
Herjavec:
It's a little harder to stop.
‐Nice job.
‐That was awesome!
[ Beeping ]
Greiner: But what if
you're in a city, right?
There's potholes,
there's, like, divots
in the streets,
sidewalks are
always like this.
So, what happens then?
Right. So,
we don't really see it
as an alternative
to walking in the city.
Oh.
Mason: The cool thing
about the Zuum shoes is,
you can throw them
in your backpack.
What is the price?
$299.
‐$299?
‐Wow.
What do they cost
landed?
Mason: $130.
So, who created this?
So, the manufacturer
designs it,
and we introduced it
into the U. S.
And we met
with a manufacturer
over in China.
We flew over to them.
Ah.
Okay, so, you're a distributor.
You didn't create it.
Okay, so it's
an already‐made product.
Mason: Right.
O'Leary: What stops me,
Mr. Wonderful,
from going
to the same manufacturer
and bringing this Zuum out
as the Wonderboard?
What stops me
from doing that?
Nothing.
But what we have is ‐‐
Nothing?!
We have our company,
we have Zuum,
and we ‐‐ in January
of this year,
we launched a Kickstarter
campaign for these,
and we raised $25,000.
Just to get
manufacturing done?
Well, we raised the money
to test the market,
because we really see
Kickstarter as a good way
to see, is there
a proof of concept?
I'm very stuck.
Mason, do you have exclusive
rights on the contract?
Tell me the deal that you made
to bring the product.
We don't have exclusive rights
on the technology.
What?!
Relax, Kevin.
This self‐balancing technology
is available for sale.
No, I get that.
But what do you have?
That's the reason
why we're here.
We want to take that money
that we're asking for
to create custom designs.
Ooh, that's a bad idea.
Guys, look, one of the key
things for any entrepreneur
is to know
what business you're in.
If you would have come in
and said, "Here's who we are.
We realize other people
can come in
and sell the same product,
but here's why we are
the best sales organization" ‐‐
you guys didn't come in
and say that, though.
You didn't tell us
that's where your expertise was.
Okay.
And for those reasons,
I'm out.
What's your biggest obstacle?
Um ‐‐ Pbht.
I think it would
just be...
I don't know.
What do you think, Chico?
It's capital‐intensive
and having the connection
of, like, a Shark.
You're not persuasive
at all.
If you were to ask me
what the obstacle was
with every single business
I've invested in,
in this moment, I can tell you
exactly what
they're confronting,
and they know it.
Okay.
So, our biggest obstacle
with this is capital.
We just ‐‐
We have opportunities.
We just can't fulfill
those opportunities
because we don't have the money
for inventory,
since it is a ‐‐
I have to stop you there.
I have never seen a business,
a young entrepreneur,
inexperienced entrepreneur
whose problem was solved
by money, period.
Yeah.
The thing that solves
every problem is passion,
and I've seen people
make huge successes
without a dime in their pocket
if they have the passion.
So ‐‐
And we will. We will.
If we don't have the capital,
we'll just grow slower,
and we can take it one step
at a time.
I say if you don't have
the passion,
you're not gonna grow,
and for simply that reason,
I'm out.
Both: Thank you, Barbara.
Greiner: I have a question.
What's your competition?
Does Segway have one?
Yes. They came out
with a pair, as well.
They're more expensive, and they
have that brand recognition.
That's why they sell
for higher.
That's everything.
That brand name
is really hard to go up against
when you're small.
So, my confusion here is,
I understand
you're repping products.
That's fine.
I'm not sure
why you picked this,
that can have so much trouble
down your road.
I feel, because you have
all those issues,
it's not a wise investment
for me today.
So I'm sorry ‐‐ I'm out.
Both: Thank you, Lori.
O'Leary: Guys, let's take stock
where we're at.
You do not own anything
in a very competitive market.
I don't want
to discourage you ‐‐
Well, maybe I do.
I actually think this sucks.
Um...I hate it.
I'm out.
Thank you.
Thanks, Kevin.
I'm just trying to go back,
what the game plan is,
'cause I'm a little unclear.
You don't make the product,
you have no exclusivity,
there's nothing proprietary
about your product.
What's the vision?
So, for the vision,
we know some manufacturers
in China
that we want
to innovate
on top of the current
electric scooter market.
We want to create
more of a catalog
of electric rideable
markets.
Robert,
what are you gonna do?
I got to tell you ‐‐
Robert, I'll do this for you.
I'm now Robert.
I'm out.
[ Laughs ]
See you later.
Look, I‐I wish you
all the best,
but I don't trust you
with my money.
I just don't trust
you're gonna be a custodian
of my money
and make more of it
with this business.
I'm out.
Okay, thank you.
Greiner: Guys, listen,
hire a great salesperson.
No, go out and sell
yourselves! It's your
product! Figure it out!
Mark, you're not gonna
give a dog a duck.
You cannot outsource sales
when you're starting.
Like, it's not their thing.
Lori, let them go
and steep in their misery!
‐Good luck, guys.
‐Thank you.
Mason: Wish we could've
came out there with more energy.
We're gonna take what they said,
and, you know,
really try to sell our product
and really market it
and just continue
what we're doing,
'cause we're
on the right path.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is an innovation
to a ubiquitous
household product.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
My name's Joe Altieri,
from Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania,
and I am the inventor
and owner of FlexScreen.
I am asking for $800,000
in exchange
for 6% of my company.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐Wow.
Everybody hates window screens.
They [Clears throat]
are next to impossible
to install and remove,
they block more of your view
than you realize,
and, of course...
this happens.
Greiner: [ Chuckles ]
And I'm here today
to show you a better way.
This is FlexScreen,
the world's first and only
flexible window screen.
That's cool.
Everybody knows
the pain associated
with removing
your window screens.
Check this out.
Wow.
Can't do that
with a regular window screen,
and you definitely can't do this
with a traditional screen.
Wow.
[ Laughs ]
FlexScreen
is an industry disrupter
and absolutely everything you
could want in a window screen.
So, who wants to join
the FlexScreen revolution
and help millions of people
enjoy their view?
What is the trim actually
made out of,
and what is
the screen material?
Yeah, so, the screen material
is standard screen material.
There's nothing different
about the material itself
compared to traditional
window screens.
Oh.
So, this is the technology.
It's actually ‐‐ this is a piece
of our frame material.
So, it's only the frame
that's the difference?
So, the inner core of this
is high‐carbon oil‐tempered
spring steel.
It's garage‐door spring
material.
Joe, how did you come up
with the idea?
So, I, um ‐‐ I'm a window guy.
For about 20 years,
I sold window screens.
So, window manufacturers
have two options ‐‐
they can buy screens
or they can make them
themselves.
So, my job was to go in
and convince somebody
to let me produce
their window screens for them.
So, um,
I just started, you know,
messing around in my garage,
trying to come up with something
that wouldn't get damaged
as easily ‐‐
my bubble‐gum
and duct‐tape prototype.
And since I was
in the industry,
showed it off to some people,
and they went bananas for it.
They said, "Hey,
get some patents,
because somebody's gonna
rip you off,
because there hasn't been
anything new
in the window industry
for a very, very long time.
Okay, Joe, I totally agree
you're the window guy.
I'm sure everybody else up here
thinks the same thing.
But I'm an investor guy,
and you're asking me
for $800,000 for 6% ‐‐
imputes a $13.3 million
valuation.
Wow.
Obviously,
we have to get to sales.
You better have some.
What do you got?
Year one, $400,000 in sales.
‐Okay.
‐Year two, $2 million in sales.
Ah.
Year three, $3.5 million.
Yes.
Year four, which is last year,
$5.1 million.
I'm liking it.
Wow.
What profits did you make
after you paid yourself
and everybody else?
So, last year, we only ‐‐
we only cleared about $40,000.
‐Ooh!
‐At $5.5 million?!
‐Wow. Wow, wow, wow.
Now, here's the thing ‐‐
We are ‐‐
Joe, baby, sweetie, honey,
what happened?
Well, we're reinvesting.
Herjavec: What was
your gross margin?
$700,000 last year.
‐Out of five ‐‐
‐Why isn't your ‐‐
So, that's ‐‐
What is that?
That's the problem.
About 15%?
Roughly, yes.
Why isn't
your margin higher?
You're a manufacturer.
Shouldn't your margin be
quite a bit higher?
Well, so, we have
four manufacturing plants,
but they're actually
licensed manufacturers for us.
We don't actually own
the plants.
Thank God.
Well,
you buy from them.
Wait, did I hear
you're a royalty business?
Very similar
to a royalty business.
Yippee‐i‐o‐ki‐yay.
Yes, I'm speaking
your language here.
Break down the numbers
for me.
So, we buy for roughly $10
from them,
and we sell for $11.50.
Wow.
Wow. Ouch.
Now, this is to
the window manufacturers.
That wasn't a "Wow, good."
Cuban: Why can't you sell
for more of a premium?
If you're the only one
and you dominate this market,
why aren't you selling them
for $15 instead of $11.50?
Because
the window manufacturers
can only get
so much for a window.
The market is absolutely huge.
So, what you're saying,
people are not willing
to pay a premium.
Well, you're not selling
to people, though.
I'm selling
to the window manufacturers.
Like I said,
that's our core business.
Why don't you let them
just do the manufacturing
and the sales
and you get a royalty?
That's an option for us.
But of course!
It's the only option!
Because you're making no money.
You're killing yourself.
No, it's not.
No, Joe, here's where
I'm disconnecting, right?
Okay.
Why can the manufacturers
not convey
to their customers
that this is
a better‐quality product
that is easier to maintain,
looks better?
Why are they not able to sell it
for a premium?
One of the issues is that
the window manufacturers
are not terribly good marketers.
So, even though
we have something better ‐‐
No, no, it's not about them
not being good marketers.
It's on you not being
a good enough marketer.
So, why haven't you been able
to get the message out?
Well, and we have been.
I mean, we're gonna do
$10 million in sales this year.
But you're gonna make
$80,000 on it.
That sucks!
No, no, no, that ‐‐ that ‐‐
I could invest the $800,000
with you, Joe,
and die of old age
before I ever get it back.
If I stopped everything today,
I would make $1 million
this year.
What if I said to you,
"Okay, Joe, I'm interested,
but all I want to do is take
this better mousetrap,
better patent,
better screen,
go to the screen guys,
and say,
'I want to license this
to you.
You're going to manufacture it
into your windows
and have the advantage
of a better screen'?"
I'm really good
at negotiating those deals.
Do you like that model versus
all the crap you're doing now?
Because you're spinning
your wheels so hard
and making no money.
Would you go
to that model?
So, to answer your question,
absolutely.
We've talked
to the major manufacturers.
And?
But the fact of the matter is,
we had to kind of get out
and make a name for ourselves.
So, you're saying you couldn't
get them to license it from you
unless you proved it
in the market first?
They want to be
very fast followers.
But you have done it.
Yes.
You've now got $5 million
through this horrible way
of making no money,
'cause you're buying it
from yourself, basically,
and then reselling it
with tiny margins.
So, you can sell
to the public.
Absolutely.
We just started on the Internet
with our own e‐commerce,
and we've done no marketing
as far as ‐‐
Are the sizes standard,
Joe,
so any guy can just order one
for his window?
They're all custom‐made.
Every one
is custom‐made?
Altieri: Every single one
is custom‐made.
Wow.
Whoa!
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
So, now you see where
some of the things like,
"Oh, you can't
just ship them from,"
you know, "New Mexico
up to Pittsburgh."
But why custom‐made?
Well, but aren't there
standard‐size windows?
Yeah, aren't the windows
all to standard?
No. The window industry
is very, very custom.
But every customer has
to be custom‐made?
Mm‐hmm.
Yeah, but I go into Lowe's,
and there's screens
all over the place.
Greiner: Yeah.
I mean, if
a traditional screen
doesn't need to be custom‐made,
why do yours?
They do. Again, if you buy
a window at Lowe's,
they might have the
replacement screens at Lowe's.
Corcoran: Hold it.
But for the most part,
if you need ‐‐
But they're
all different sizes.
They're all different sizes.
That's just crazy to me.
You have a better product...
It's amazing.
...each one is custom‐made,
and you only have
15% margins.
I mean, if I invested, I'd be
like ‐‐ pbht ‐‐ crush that.
We're going to
100%‐plus margins.
I don't care if I sell
10% as much,
but I'm gonna make
a whole lot more money.
We want volume.
We want to be the every screen
out there on these windows.
Every window that goes out ‐‐
No, you want to be
the premium screen.
Because
in the next couple years,
as it becomes the standard
in the industry,
I can charge whatever I want.
But, Joe, you can't!
You can't.
No, I see where
you're trying to go, Joe.
Mm‐hmm.
I have to assume
that you went
to the manufacturers
and tried to sell it
for more,
and the manufacturers
said to you,
"Our consumers don't care."
They said, "This is great.
It's a premium product."
It solves a lot
of problems for them.
"But I'm not willing
to pay more."
Not a lot more.
I'm out.
Joe, I would like
to give you an offer.
Wow.
But I want to tell you,
I replace the screens
in my beach house
every third year.
Those damn mosquitos
find a way of getting in, okay?
[ Chuckles ]
I'm listening to you.
I am in the habit
of ordering screens,
and I noticed when I have
the catalogue,
'cause I keep it now,
there are certain screen sizes,
but the great majority
of the sales
are roughly
12 different screen sizes,
from what I could see.
So, my offer is independent
of what you're doing right now.
I'll give you $400,000
in cash,
$400,000 in credit
to be used to manufacture
standard sizes,
and I want to take 50%
of the right
to sell it online
and in stores.
I think this is
a huge profit‐maker,
but you just went down
the wrong road to begin with.
Wow.
Your go‐to‐market strategy
was awful.
Corcoran: Yeah.
Like, 50% of the equity
in this other company,
alright?
What other company?
Altieri:
She wants to start a retail ‐‐
The other company
to manufacture
and produce consumer goods
in standard sizes to be sold.
That's it.
You keep doing your deal
with the other guys.
That's how much she hates
your business model.
[ Laughs ]
Cuban: Honestly, Joe,
I think she's right.
I'll make you an offer.
I'm gonna take you to the
number‐one window manufacturer.
I want to take
this better mousetrap,
get them to use it
on every window,
which I don't think
you've really tried to do yet.
I'll give you the $800,000,
I want 20% of the business,
straight equity,
but I only want to work
with one big manufacturer.
I don't want to do
all the rest of this crap.
Herjavec: You've got
two offers already.
One Shark's out,
two are...
Altieri: Yes.
...thinking.
Another one's coming.
♪♪
O'Leary: Uh‐oh.
Narrator: One Shark is out.
Joe has two offers on the table,
from Kevin and Barbara,
for his flexible window screen
company, FlexScreen.
But Lori is also interested.
I like selling
to the window manufacturers,
and I like selling
to the consumer.
So, I would give you
$400,000 up front,
then I'd give you $400,000
as a line of credit.
I'm gonna do it
at 3‐year, 6%.
That's the interest.
Interest, right,
on the loan.
I'm gonna want still
10% equity stake in the company,
and I'll tell you why.
I can help you
get that to fit
into other windows
all over
and make it more standard
so that then you can be
more successful
when you go into retail
at Lowe's and Home Depot.
Herjavec:
That's a great offer.
And I have been heavily
in the hardware space.
Altieri: Mm‐hmm.
A lot of my entrepreneurs
are in the hardware space.
And, um, I think
that we could
really do something great
with this,
'cause I think you need
to be to the consumer
and to the window makers.
Herjavec: Joe, you were looking
for 6%. She only wants 10%.
This is a great offer.
Lori's
in a very happy mood.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐Yeah.
Okay, I'll make it a little
more interesting for you.
I'll loan you
the entire $800,000, okay?
I'm gonna charge you 9%
on it.
I'm gonna take 6% equity
in the company.
It's venture debt.
And then I won't put
any covenants on you,
but I'll guide your team in
terms of how to make more money,
'cause I know
how to fix this problem.
Mark,
are you in or out?
I think, you know, what
these guys have said is right.
You know, you need to be able
to use your factories better.
I'm not the window guy,
even though I like
to help everybody
from Pittsburgh,
but for those reasons,
I'm out.
Joe, the window of opportunity
is closing.
Pick one.
O'Leary: You know,
the simplest deal is mine
'cause it doesn't have
any contingencies.
If the business fails,
I get wiped out. Let's be clear.
And the smartest deal is mine
because it will make you
the most money.
Too complicated,
Barbara.
It's not complicated at all.
I don't understand it.
Truthfully, I mean,
I appreciate all the offers.
I'm leaning towards ‐‐
no offense, Mr. Wonderful ‐‐
to one of the beautiful ladies.
Well, why don't you pick
the prettiest girl?
I'm right here.
[ Laughs ]
Why don't you offer Lori
the side of the business
that's the clunker, where
you have ‐‐ making you money?
I don't see that side
of your business as a clunker.
She's excited, okay?
I like my side of the business.
Mm.
I like
the window manufacturers,
so, you know, having a separate
retail company, um...
Interesting, interesting.
...I'm actually
leaning towards that.
Ooh.
And I'll tell you
something else.
My younger brother, Marty,
Joe, in Oregon,
is in your business.
Really?
He's a huge hit.
And he's looking
to do something else.
Guess what, Joe.
I'd help you get it.
I'll do that same deal.
You can't get
my brother Marty, Lori.
[ Laughter ]
No. I can't get Marty.
I can't get Marty,
but I'll do the same deal.
Um, would either one of you
be willing
to up the cash
versus the line of credit
to sweeten the pot?
No.
What are you going to do?
I, uh ‐‐ I do think that you
have the better connections
with the hardware space,
and I've love to partner up
with you on that deal.
Ah [bleep]
Whoo!
I mean, oh, damn it!
[ Laughter ]
‐Awesome.
‐Wow.
Corcoran: Well,
that's not only losing a deal,
but watching somebody steal
your idea and lose the deal.
Sorry, Barb.
I'm sorry.
That's alright...
Congratulations.
...I guess.
Thank you, guys.
Good job, Joe.
It's going to change everything
about our company,
and partnering with Lori
is gonna be fantastic.
I'm just so excited,
I can't even contain myself.
Ooh, Barbara's giving me
the evil stare.
Lori, it wasn't fair.
You to play dirty,
and I don't like it.
But I'm a lot prettier than you,
so I'm gonna get over it.
[ Laughs ]
♪♪